Okay.
Well,
as you know,
in 15,
28,
religious change had not been a significant issue in English politics.
By 1558,
it was in many ways the central issue.
And it was about to take another turn.
Uh,
on the 17th of November,
1558,
Elizabeth the first was proclaimed Queen Young Woman of 25,
highly intelligent what educated and long schooled in the necessity of caution,
discretion and even dissimulation in order to survive the dangers that she had
faced.
She was of course,
an Berlin's daughter and as ambulance daughter,
it was in a sense her conception in December of 1532 that had finally
precipitated the assertion of Henry the eighth royal supremacy.
So you could say in a sense that Elizabeth's whole identity and above all her
claims to the throne,
we're bound up with the rejection by her father of papal authority.
Not the precise nature of her personal beliefs remains uncertain.
Um,
she didn't really disclose them,
but unquestionably,
she identified herself with the Protestant cause.
Um,
shortly after her ex session that Christmas 1558,
she very ostentatiously walked out of mass in the Royal Chapel at the point at
which the host was elevated.
A month later in January,
1559 she very ostentatiously embraced an English Bible which was offered to her
by the citizens of London on her state entry to London prior to her coronation.
So Elizabeth was making no secret of the fact that she inclined towards reform
as indeed everyone expected.
But if you inclined towards reform,
she was neither dogmatically,
north straight forwardly Protestant and the religious settlement of 1559 the
first business of her reign very much reflected that fact.
It was in part the product of theological convictions,
but it was also very much a settlement that reflected earlage his preference
that was tempered by sheer political expediency.
What actually happened remains rather cloudy.
Some aspects of the documentation are inadequate,
but the most convincing interpretation of the settlement to my mind is that of a
Norman Jones.
In his view,
Elizabeth and her chief advisor,
William sessile,
intended initially to return to the situation of 1552 just before the death of
her brother Edward,
the sixth.
But they met severe opposition in parliament,
particularly in the House of Lords.
Opposition not only from the Catholic bishops who sat in the Lords,
but also from some of the leading lay members of the peerage.
And so they had to return to parliament with a distinctly watered down draft
prayer book,
setting out their desires for religious settlement.
So for example,
in 1559 in the prayer book they brought to parliament,
the communion service was in fact a blend of the prayer book of 1552 with its
very protestant,
uh,
statements regarding the communion service being essentially a service of
remembrance and Thanksgiving.
They blended that with the earlier 1549 prayer book,
which had allowed for the possibility that there was a real presence of Christ,
body and blood in the communion service.
And so in 1559 the wording at the administration of the communion was it was as
follows,
it read the body of our Lord Jesus Christ,
which was given for the preserve thy body and soul unto everlasting life.
That's 1549 followed immediately by take and eat this in remembrance that Christ
died for the and feed on him in my heart by faith with thanksgiving,
that's 1552 they blended the two together so that you could read it as you
chose.
It's been described by Dermot Mcculloch has a masterpiece of theological
engineering or fudging the issue.
You could say
again in 1559 the bill brought before parliament put forward the title for
Elizabeth,
not of Supreme Head of the Church of England,
but only of supreme governor that's often seen as being a more appropriate title
for a woman governor rather than head.
But it also of course left open the possibility that the settlement might be
accepted,
that the position of supreme governor might be accepted by people who regarded
the supreme head of the church as being elsewhere in Rome.
Even so,
despite these compromisers,
Elizabeth and her counselors were able to get their settlement through
parliament only by purging the House of Lords.
They ruthlessly excluded many of the Catholic bishops in the end,
and they still got a majority of only three votes.
They squeezed it through the House of Lords.
Supporting the Commons was much stronger.
So the Church of England was reestablished.
England was Protestant.
Again,
sort of.
It was a confessional state bound by an act of uniformity that the prayer book
should be used throughout the kingdom.
Uniformity to the religion set down by the queen in parliament,
what was often described as the religion by law established,
but that religion was less imposed by simple royal diktat than a reflection of
what Elizabeth and her advisors had proved,
willing to settle for.
There was no doubt that England had turned in a pro broadly Protestant direction
again,
but there was also a lot of ambiguity about the nature and the extent of that
Protestantism.
Okay,
well maybe Elizabeth and William sessile and the other counselors got less than
they originally intended,
but they accepted it and they could even use it to their advantage.
It was perhaps no bad thing in the England of 1559 that the religious settlement
contained a lot of ambiguity.
30 years of religious flux had left the nation profound,
profound,
the divided in matters of faith.
No change during those 30 years had had time to put down deep roots to some
historians like Christopher.
Hey,
most of the people remained in the main traditionalists in their religious
beliefs,
uh,
to other historians like Robert Whiting.
People had grown almost indifferent,
acquiescing and conforming to change after change,
but essentially guarded and an UN enthusiastic in their attitudes.
But also,
as you've seen in last week's reading,
there was a third reading of the situation represented by the work of
Christopher Marsh people.
We're now only too aware of the existence of alternatives in religion
alternatives,
which hadn't existed back in the 1520s.
Some of them Hank had after the old ways.
Some of them were drawn to the attractive features of the new doctrines.
But everyone knew the danger of religious conflict.
They'd witnessed enough of that under Mary as a result of marsh suggests they
held their piece and as you know,
he uses that term in a double sense.
Negativity in the sense that they were compliant.
They remained silent before the demands of authority,
positively in the sense that they preserved the piece of their own communities
as best they could.
One could say that that was an attitude that had developed as a result of the
turmoil of the late 1540s and early 1550s in particular.
Um,
even under Mary,
uh,
the mayor of Exeter in the West down here in Devin was a man who,
although I'm a devout Catholic in his own practice,
regarded Protestant sympathizers among his neighbors with some discretion and
tolerance.
It was said of him that he did friendly and lovingly bear with them and wink at
them.
He shut his eyes to their practice.
I one could say that Elizabeth was winking at people too.
She winked to people in many ways.
She was the supreme governor of the Church of England.
She was the head of a confessional state.
But she also said early in her reign,
I will not make windows into men's souls.
A striking metaphor.
What she and her counselors wanted was order outward conformity,
stability,
and in pursuit of those objectives,
the ambiguities of 1559 were in many ways advantageous and they could be
developed
soon after the passage of the settlement through parliament,
um,
a set of injunctions concerning worship are issued.
They permitted the images which had survived Protestant iconoclasm to remain in
churches so long as they were not superstitiously abused.
They said that in future communion tables were to be used for holy communion
rather than alters.
But nonetheless,
the communion table could stand where the old ulta had stood.
I totally communion traditional wafers we used rather than common bread.
The women he concessions of this kind,
Elizabeth herself would have liked to have kept the rood screens above the
chancel with their crucifixes,
et cetera.
She kept a crucifix in her own Chapel,
but her more Protestant bishops really wouldn't stand for that.
And many routes,
screens what graduate dismantled throughout the kingdom.
In the course of the 1560s
or again in dealing with the clergy,
she faced in parliament bishops who put up such a stiff opposition that she was
forced to deprive them.
She would have liked them to stay.
They didn't,
but new appointments to the episcopal bench where rarely religious extremists
was significant that you chose as Archbishop of Canterbury,
Matthew Parker,
a Cambridge academic who was a protestant certainly,
but two had not gone into exile and Mary,
he had conformed and kept his head down.
She considered Parker a more appropriate choice than some of them are radical
Protestants that she could have selected
amongst the parish clergy to there was no mass purge.
Many of the clergy were allowed to keep their positions and even to get away
with formerly subscribing to the prayer book and the Act of uniformity,
but continuing many traditional practices on hindered
the toleration,
which was extended to traditional practices,
allowed them to preserve in many ways the appearance of tradition in the way
they conducted services in their parishes.
Christopher Haigh has a nice phrase for it.
He says,
many of these people were liturgical hermaphrodites.
They use the prayer book,
but they could tweak it their own way.
Again,
fines were laid down for people who fail to attend the Church of England at
least once a month,
but they were set very low.
The fine was 12 pence a month.
If you fail to attend Church of England services,
which was about the equivalent of a day's wages for a London labor.
Not a steep fine at all.
So what did it all mean?
Clearly that is a birth was no catholic,
but she refused to persecute.
And equally she refused to countenance any further reform.
She seems to have learned a lesson in 1559 about the art of the possible and she
stuck to it.
And that came up very clearly,
just a few years later in 1563 when it's a meeting of the convocation of the
Church of England,
the assembly of the clergy of the Church of England,
there occurred what's known as the Vestey area and controversy.
Uh,
some of the more radical Protestants in convocation wanted to get rid of
traditional vestments worn by the priest during services.
They described them as the rags of Rome.
These however,
had been retained in the prayer book of 1559 and Elizabeth insisted upon
retaining traditional clerical dress and forced Archbishop Parker to demand it
of the clergy.
So what was England religion in the fifties and sixties?
Ultimately,
one could say it was the queen's religion.
With regard to the pope's authority,
it was emphatically schismatic.
Papal Authority had been abrogated once again,
with regard to essential doctrines,
it was essentially Protestant,
but nonetheless,
it retained a latitude to make of the settlement to read the prayer book as you
chose,
provided you conformed.
In general,
the only element of settlement one could say which was totally without ambiguity
was the act of uniformity,
conform
and hold your peace.
Well,
in an age of religious partisanship,
in what was already becoming in Europe and age of religious war,
that was not really a bad deal,
but of course it couldn't stand there.
Whatever the ambiguity's of the settlement,
first of all,
no one could really doubt that it was basically Protestant in orientation and
secondly,
no one yet knew that Elizabeth would live to be 70
and those two facts shape the attitudes of both committed Catholics and the more
committed protestants.
And by 1560 of course there were plenty of both.
Both groups of zealots were preoccupied with what might happen next.
Would that be another turn of the wheel?
What Elizabeth survive on both sides were determined to do what they could to
shape events to their own advantage.
If such a possibility of future change emerged.
So let's look at the two groups who opposed in different ways the Elizabethan
settlement and how their challenges were met.
We can start by looking at the Catholics.
Christopher Haigh argues persuasively.
I think that there was a great deal of what he calls traditionalist survivalism
to a considerable degree.
The idea there's a booth and church was attempting to accommodate that
traditionalism amongst the population as a whole,
but the more committed,
more theologically aware and more politically aware,
Catholics knew that this was a recipe for the gradual erosion of Catholic
principle.
There were a lot of people who were described at the time as church papists in
the fifties and sixties people whose bodies were in the Church of England,
as it were,
but whose hearts remained with the old religion,
such people would gradually become hopelessly compromised over time unless
something was done to stiffen their resistance to a gradual slide into
conformity and acceptance of the new ways
I did the eyes of those who feared this.
There was,
after all,
every possibility that the settlement of 1559 would not endure any longer than
other changes.
It all hung on the life of one young woman and in 1562 Elizabeth contracted
smallpox and almost died.
Her counselors were in a panic as she lay on her sick bed.
She recovered,
but it was a warning of what could happen.
We have to remember this,
this vital element of uncertainty.
Whenever we look at the Elizabeth,
Elizabeth,
and church and indeed it other aspects of her reign.
So you get in these years the gradual emergence of what might be called a kind
of shadow church or a church in exile,
waiting for the possibility of a return to the old ways and the years 1568 to
1570 to be in many ways a turning point for these Catholics.
In 1568,
William Allen,
uh,
a former Oxford don who had fled to the continent founder the college or do a in
the Netherlands for the purpose of training priests who would be smuggled back
into England and who could operate in secrecy to stiffen the faith of English
Catholics
in the same year.
In May of 1568,
Mary Stewart,
the Queen of Scotland,
a Catholic,
was deposed by her own subjects and fled into England.
They asked,
she was kept under house arrest by Elizabeth,
but while she remained,
she was clearly a claimant to the English throne within reach of those who are
posting Elizabeth,
but she was Elizabeth's nearest relative,
a cousin and a Catholic.
I'll say more about Mary Queen of Scots next time,
but her presence is a constant factor in the equation.
In 1567 to 68 almost simultaneously came the outbreak of the Dutch revolt revolt
of the provinces of the Netherlands,
just across the narrow see against Spanish rule,
which led to the establishment in the Netherlands have a powerful Spanish army
to put down that revolt sent by King Phillip the second of Spain,
the champion of the counter reformation in Europe.
It's arrival was followed by a massive repression of Protestants in the
Netherlands and the flight of many of them to England.
And in the following year in 1569 came the revolt of the northern Earl's
that began with a plot to release Mary Queen of Scots from captivity to marry
her to the Duke of Norfolk,
who was a crypto Catholic,
to restore her to the Scottish thrown with the help of the Spanish army,
which was just over the seas in the Netherlands.
And to depose Elizabeth when the scheme was discovered by Elizabeth's
intelligence service,
the olds of Northumberland and of Westmoreland,
the two dominant nobles of the North Rose and rebellion.
They raised about 5,000 men.
They captured the city of Durham.
They restored the mass in Durham Cathedral.
They moved gradually south.
The government responded to the rising by securing Mary and moving her south out
of their reach.
She was placed under the tutelage of the Earl of Shrosbree down in the Midlands.
The northern Earl's fail to move swiftly.
They got bogged down besieging a castle near Durham,
which was held by the loyal Bose family for Elizabeth,
and eventually realizing that their support was eroding.
They gave up and fled into Scotland.
There then followed up two years of diplomatic and military bullying before.
Eventually the Earl of Northumberland was surrendered back to the English and
was executed by then.
The rebellion was long over by December,
1569 it had proved to be a fiasco and it fizzled out,
but in February 15th 70 rather too late,
the pope having heard of it,
offered his support.
He excommunicated Elizabeth and he absorbed her subjects from their obedience to
the Queen.
He was telling her Catholic subjects,
in other words,
that rebellion against this heritage queen was no sin,
a little too late,
but nonetheless at last,
a clarifying decision on the part of the papacy.
With regard to Elizabeth,
the
for,
for the Catholic subjects of the Queen in 1568 to 71 could say the moment of
truth had at last come.
At last they had been principled resistance to the Elizabeth and settlement.
At last,
there had been a lead from the papacy,
but in a sense it was also a disaster for the average traditionalist in
religion.
Now,
they were in a position where they had to choose,
they had to make a stand like it or not.
Geopolitical realities increasingly demanded it and for many of them that was an
absolutely agonizing situation
and they didn't.
He has had followed in many ways.
It got worse from the 15 from the mid 1570s missionary priests trained in the
Netherlands,
began arriving to stiffen the faith of the Catholic faithful.
There was something like 60 who arrived in the course of a later 1570s between
then and the end of the reign in 1,603 something like 500 Catholic priests were
smuggled into England to operate in secret from the 1580s they were joined by
another group,
the Jesuits,
the shock troops of the Catholic counter reformation in Europe who joined in the
mission to England.
Yeah.
Now,
of course from their perspective,
these were heroic people
and yet they were fatally compromised by their association with a Foreign Power
Spain,
and they were inevitably associated with the dynamics of religious conflict in
Europe,
not least because some of the leaders of the Catholic mission subscribe to the
view that it was no sin to depose or even murder a heretical Monique
and so began a series of plots which were uncovered throughout the middle and
later years of Elizabeth's reign in 1571 the Ridalfi plot to depose Elizabeth
Place Mary Queen of Scots on the throne,
Mary her to the Duke of Norfolk that ended in 1572 with the execution of Norfolk
in 1572 the news came from France of the Saint Bartholomew's massacre of
Protestants in Paris.
This seemed a demonstration of a broad of the risk of catholic treachery.
In 1583 the Throckmorton plot to murder Elizabeth was uncovered a year later in
1584 the leader of the Dutch Protestants,
William the silent,
was murdered in the Netherlands in 50 and 86 the Babington plot to depose
Elizabeth and elevate Mary Queen of Scots to the throne was uncovered.
The atmosphere then was one of tremendous insecurity and the government's
response was severe.
In 1581 it was declared by parliament treason to be absolved from schism with
Rome and to be reconciled to the Catholic church records and see fines for not
attending.
The Church of England were raised from one shillings a month to 20 pounds.
That's a 400 fold increase in the size of requisites he finds.
In 1585 England was at last after long hesitation brought to declare open war
with Spain and to send troops to the Netherlands to help stiff and the
resistance of the Dutch Protestants.
And in the same year,
parliament made it treason for any ordained priest of the Catholic Church.
Even to enter England for a priest to be found on English soil was treason in
1586 following the Babington plot,
Mary Queen of Scots was at last brought to trial,
sentenced to death.
And then after long hesitation on the part of Elizabeth finally beheaded in
February,
1587 and then in 1588,
the whole nation was mobilized to resist the threat of invasion by the Spanish
armada great fleet sent by Philip the second intended to pick up troops in the
Netherlands,
transport them across the narrow sees and attack London,
um,
a plan which was eventually foiled only by the resistance,
which was put up by the English fleet in the channel.
And then the scattering of Spanish ships as they sailed north and eventually
around Scotland and Ireland to return to Spain.
Many of them being lost on the way,
following the,
what was seen as the divine deliverance in the modern campaign.
The war dragged on right through to the end of Elizabeth's reign.
Well in such a context,
any priest who landed in England to do God's work amongst the Catholic faithful
as they saw it,
we're inevitably regarded by the government as the traitor,
his servants of a foreign power
between 50 and 81 and 1,603 131 catholic priests were arrested and executed
together with 60 of the lay people who had hid them.
All of them being executed as traitors.
These are those who are regarded in English Catholic tradition as the Catholic
martyr's
and in a nation that was increasingly prone to regard itself as a big league at
island,
threatened by mighty enemies.
Catholicism almost inevitably became tainted by its association with that
threat.
Of course,
that was mistaken.
Many of the Catholic nobility and Gentry went out of their way to stress their
loyalty to Elizabeth that they would not support any foreign invasion.
They would indeed,
sometimes openly declared themselves as sufficiently loyal to oppose it.
They were well known.
They will often trusted as individuals by their Protestant neighbors,
the fines levied upon them for their Catholic requisite.
We're often very selectively and intermittently and forced amongst the Catholic
population as a whole.
There was only a tiny number of zealots who were ever actively involved in
treasonable plots,
especially against the queen's life.
Nevertheless,
be that as it may in the situation after 1570 and especially after the outbreak
of war in 1585 the catholic community as an entity lay under the shadow of
distrust and it was subject to a developing prejudice which would take centuries
to dispel.
As Patrick Collinson has written,
Anti Catholicism became almost a sheet anchor of English nationhood and the
Catholic community within England became in a sense aliens within their own
land.
Okay.
What about the other threat?
The Radical Protestants,
those who we think of now as puritans,
that that was not a term they used initially.
It was a term of insult that was sometimes thrown at them.
They were described usually at the time as the hotter sort of Protestants,
the hottest sort of Protestants
to them.
The accession of Elizabeth in 1558 had been a providential deliverance,
a divine intervention in English affairs.
November the 17th the queen's accessing day was celebrated with the ringing of
bells.
It became almost like a Protestant holy day,
but though they regarded the church of England,
which he established a year later in 1559 as undoubtedly a true church,
it seemed to these Protestant radicals that it was a church which was only half
reformed
and they too were worried about what happened,
what might happen next.
They could have no certainty that it would last.
They were anxious to push ahead to consolidate the position to move version the
to what they described as further reformation
especially they wanted reformation of some of the traditional structures of the
Church of England and the removal of some of the more traditional aspects of its
forms of worship.
They wanted to get rid of the rags of Rome or the dregs of popery.
This is the sort of language they used.
So there was from the beginning,
an element of dissidence even amongst those who could be regarded as Elizabeth,
most enthusiasts supporters.
And that was especially true amongst the younger clergy who were emerging from
the universities now thoroughly trained in Protestant doctrine.
And who we're becoming,
if anything,
more emphatically Protestant even than those who would lead the church.
In the later years of Edward,
the sixth
this younger generation,
we're moving beyond the doctrinal position,
which had been established by Archbishop Cranmer in the early 1550s and was
enshrined in the prayer book.
Increasingly,
they felt the influence of John Calvin,
the Great Protestant leader of Geneva and his successor there.
They had all Beazer
in terms of the doctrine of salvation.
They increasingly adopted the doctrine of predestination,
championed by Calvin.
The notion that only an elect minority would find salvation.
Many also adopted the doctrine of double predestination,
champion by basin,
the view that God had decreed from the beginning of the world who would be elect
and who would be damned.
This kind of belief,
bread amongst them are very anxious.
Spirituality at the individual level.
They were deeply anxious about their own spiritual state.
Were they or were they not amongst the elect?
They tended to indulge an intense spiritual self searching rigorous attempts to
sanctify their personal lives in a way that would give them a sense of assurance
of their own election.
It was also a kind of theological position,
which bread,
what's been described as a PI board mentality.
They saw things in very black and white terms,
a piebald mentality.
The godly saw themselves as a beleaguered minority in a world that was dominated
by the reprobate,
the unregenerate.
They tended to describe themselves as the little flock,
a godly remnant.
Okay.
And that in turn seems to have bread amongst them.
I kind of activist mentality.
There was a duty to demonstrate their own godliness by standing up for the honor
of God,
by doing his work in the world by truth,
by combating sin,
an error,
a form of activism,
which in a sense could give them greater assurance.
For the most part,
they did that work in relative obscurity.
Down in the many parishes of the kingdom.
Puritans were amongst the most zealous preachers.
They were often chosen as lecturers,
people who would be hired by local authorities to preach extra sermons on market
days,
for example,
or on the weekdays.
In some areas,
they were numerous enough.
By the 1572 found regular meetings of sympathizers,
which were known as prophesied rings.
Uh,
these were meetings of the local clergy who would get together to hear a sermon,
a two debate its doctrine.
They often open these meetings.
The members of the Laity.
It was thought to be an excellent method of improving clerical knowledge,
uh,
of passing on theological knowledge to the Godly Laity.
Uh,
and uh,
in,
in areas of some areas of the country.
They were extremely influential in influencing the whole tone of local religious
life.
Um,
east Anglia was a great area of Puritan strength.
There were eight of these prophesizing meetings and the county of Suffolk in the
middle of East Anglia and in the county of Essex just to the south.
There were six of them operating by the early 15,
seventies.
But after 15,
70,
puritanism also began to acquire something of a political edge
specifically that came in the form of a movement to try to formally alter the
structures of the Church of England and to purge the prayer book of what they
saw as traditional papist survivals.
Those who became involved in it.
We're convinced that the new testament laid down a clear model of church
government,
that it did not involve bishops,
that it should be based upon autonomous congregations who elected their own
ministers and elders who would in turn meet together at a higher level in
counsels and synods to govern the church as a whole.
In other words,
a Presbyterian system of church government.
This is what they desired and advocates of such a system.
What amount of series of challenges to the Elizabethan settlement between 1517
and 1587 and there were a number of landmarks in that process.
In 1570 for example,
the professor of divinity at the University of Cambridge,
Thomas Cartwright gave a series of lectures in the university in which he argued
that the English church failed to follow the model of the New Testament and
advocated a Presbyterian system.
There was a tremendous controversy in the university.
As a result,
Cartwright in fact lost his job.
He was quickly picked up by one of Elizabeth's,
the out of Lester,
who sympathized with the puritans and placed in a living elsewhere.
So he survived.
But he lost his position at the university
in 1571 in parliament,
one member William Strickland introduced a bill to revise the Preble can purge
it.
Members of the council sitting in Parliament,
um,
oppose this move.
He was cold before the Royal Privy Council and warned not to trespass on the
queen's prerogative in matters of religion.
But a year later when parliament met again John Field and Thomas Wilcox to
leading puritans published the admonition to parliament and outspoken attack
upon the structure of the Church of England as not being a truly reformed
church,
calling them in parliament to take steps to further reform it.
Indeed,
it was so extreme and some of its statements that had greatly scandalized a
moderates amongst Protestants.
And there was no,
um,
successful action in parliament.
In 1576 they came a further attempt to discuss the church in parliament.
And on that occasion,
Elizabeth had to intervene personally to ban discussion of religion in
parliament.
The Queen also became convinced in that year that the prophesizing meetings
where a destabilizing influence on the church in the localities.
She ordered Archbishop Grindle to put a stop to them.
The archbishop protested.
He thought they were doing good work.
They were beneficial to the clergy.
As a result of the queen simply suspended.
Him and the Archbishop of Canterbury himself was suspended from exercising his
duties from 1577 through to his death in 1583
well,
at that point,
grindle's death in 1583 it could be said in a sense to symbolize the passing
away of the first generation of Elizabethan bishops.
Many of them people who have sympathized with the desire for further reformation
within the church.
Men who had been willing to serve,
willing to bear with the Elizabeth and compromise for the time being but in
their hearts would have liked to have seen more.
The phrase that was often used for people like that was that they were willing
to Terry for the magistrate.
They were willing to wait until such time as the queen was willing to move
further in a Protestant direction
and they were gradually being replaced by people of a different stamp and the
most significant of the new bishops to emerge was the new archbishop of
Canterbury.
John Wick gift
with gift was a very different kind of man from Grindle.
He was a Calvinist in his doctrine.
No products could ask for more in terms of his theological position,
but he was also a man who had grown up with the Elizabethan settlement and two
was deeply committed to the settlement in itself.
In addition to which she was a firm disciplinarian and in 1583 as a means of
preventing further action on the part of puritans with gift introduced what was
known as the three articles to which each of the clergy was required to
subscribe.
They included recognition of the royal supremacy,
recognition of the 39 articles of religion laying down the doctrine of the
Church of England and taking an oath that there was nothing in the prayer book
which was contrary to the word of God.
He proceeded to use the church courts in particularly has his own court of high
commission to examine suspected dissidents within the church under oath and to
administer the three articles.
He was in fact prevented by members of Elizabeth's council,
sympathetic to the puritan cause from taking this policy as far as he would've
liked.
Nonetheless,
it was a clear statement of his unwillingness to tolerate dissidents from
radical Protestants.
Well,
the advent of wit gift perhaps provoked what turned out to be the Presbyterian
or puritans final throw.
Some of the prophesies meetings,
which are now forbidden,
simply went underground in some areas.
They developed into what's known as the classes movement,
secret meetings of the clergy who were practicing a kind of underground
Presbyterianism John Field,
one of the authors of the admonition to parliament in 1572 built up quite an
extensive network of Presbyterian sympathizers amongst the clergy and the Laity
throughout the kingdom.
And that network was activated in 1580 450 and 86 to try to introduce further
bills into parliament calling for a Presbyterian system system.
And the revision of the prayer book.
These attempts were against scotched by royal counselors sitting in parliament
in 1586 for example,
parliament itself sent both the promoter of the bill and those who defended it
in parliament to the tower of London briefly to cool their heels.
The Presbyterians had failed again,
but the aspiration and the frustration that they felt it was vividly expressed
in 1550 and 88 to nine in the secret publication of a number of extremely
scurrilous attacks upon the bishops of the Church of England.
These were known as the Mar prelate tracts.
They were directed against bishops prelates,
the Mar prelate tracts.
The Archbishop of Canterbury instigated an investigation to discover secret
press that was producing them,
and in the course of that John Fields pure network was uncovered and the
movement was essentially smashed.
Meanwhile,
as the 1580s drew to a close,
some of the leaders of puritanism,
we're dying away.
John Field died in 1588 some are for sympathizers in the Royal Council.
Did you have Leicester?
So Francis Walsingham.
So Walter Mildmay all died in 1589 or 50 90
puritanism as a political movement was over for the time being,
but it left three legacies.
First of all,
there were small groups of puritan extreme as to was so disillusioned that they
broke from the church of England altogether formed separatist congregations
meeting in secret.
One of their leaders said that they had decided they would have reformation
without tarrying for any,
they wouldn't Terry for the magistrate,
they would have reformation without tarrying for any,
some of them would eventually forced to flee abroad.
Uh,
the group led by Robert Brown based in the city of knowledge removed themselves
to the Netherlands to escape potential persecution.
Another group led by Henry Barrow in London,
went underground and some of them eventually also emigrated to the Netherlands
where they enjoyed religious freedom in the Protestant areas of the Netherlands.
Henry Barrow returning to England at one point was arrested and was eventually
hanged for sedition was from long studies,
groups of radical separate as to a broken completely with the Church of England.
That's some of the Mayflower pilgrims of 1620 what eventually to be drawn.
So one legacy was separatism,
a tiny minority who broke away completely.
Secondly,
there was a much broader legacy of activist evangelism within the Church of
England.
Many puritans sympathizers felt that if they could not change the structures of
the Church of England,
then they could at least transform its spirit and thereby leave their own
distinctive stamp on the nature of English Protestantism.
They advocated a religion heavily based upon the Bible,
advocating,
preaching,
practicing the sanctification of the sabbath,
insisting upon strict moral behavior,
pursuing moral reformation where they had the power and the opportunity,
and they constantly drummed upon the theme of the failure of England to live up
to the,
to show proper gratitude for God's deliverance of the kingdom,
the need to turn to a more strict religious observation in,
in return for God's favor.
So that was a second legacy.
Thirdly,
there was a legacy of a different kind.
Some of those who had defended Elizabeth and settlement from Puritan attacks
began to develop an altogether more positive view of the Elizabethan settlement.
They began to see it not just as a temporary compromise,
but as a distinctive and valid alternative,
a distinctive middle way between Catholicism on the one hand and radical
Protestantism on the other
Clo gins like Richard Hooker and Richard Bancroft saw the retention of a
traditionalist structure in the Church of England does not simply a matter of
convenience or political expediency,
but as a valid Protestant alternative.
Indeed in Bancroft's view,
a divinely ordained form of church government in which England maintain the
tradition which descended from Christ's apostles,
purified of the corruptions which had crept in and the Catholic Middle Ages.
So a new one more positive notion of Anglicanism as a middle way was also
emerging amongst the defenders of the church.
Dammit.
Mcculloch has said of this,
that perhaps the Anglican gift to the Christian story is the ability to make a
virtue of necessity.
But what finally about those who were neither Catholics nor radical puritans?
No Anglican divine's the mass of the people down in the parishes.
It's been said that for most of them,
the reformation under Elizabeth was essentially a series of conforming
experiences,
a slow shift from the visual and ritual and symbolic richness of late medieval
religion to a somewhat plainer,
more verbal religion based on the English Bible,
based on the prayer book of 1559 including such things as more frequent
preaching,
psalm singing another novel practices.
That process of gradual shift in religious culture was probably aided by the
elements of continuity observable in Church of England services and gradually it
did its work.
The older generation of both the clergy and the Laity who could remember the old
days had largely died away by the 15th eighties and increasing proportion of the
population knew no other church than that of Elizabeth.
They faced no serious threat from the Catholic mission.
The Catholic missionary priests concentrated their attention on politically
significant people.
Most of their work was done amongst the gentry.
There was no real mission to the common people and by 1,603 the church of
England had something like two and a half million communicants.
While they were only some 8,000 to 9,000 known Catholic requisites.
Most of the members of the gentry or their immediate tenants sheltered under
their protection.
To this extent,
one could say that the Catholic trek was actually diminished.
Meanwhile,
the Anglican clergy were gradually adapting to their role as pastors and
teachers.
Initially,
they'd been a severe shortage of preachers and have educated clergy,
but steady work by the bishops steady work or deigning young men.
And the university's meant that by the death of Elizabeth preaching was
commonplace in most areas of the kingdom.
The clergy were increasingly university graduates.
That level of learning was improving
the most severe and the more demanding of the clergy could be highly critical of
the religious attitudes of the common people.
Some of them saw the common people as being perhaps d Catholicized,
perhaps hostile to papal authority,
but scarcely protestantized in any deep and meaningful sense.
But perhaps that's too harsh a judgment on people who've been nicely described
as parish Anglicans or prayer book.
Anglicans,
building up a loyalty to the form of religion with which they were familiar by
the 50 nineties it's likely that they certainly thought of themselves as being
members of the Protestant family as it were,
even if their theological grasp on exactly what that meant was probably rather
shaky.
At the same time,
of course,
it remains the case that puritan saw the reformation has essentially unfinished
amongst the population at large
and there were a fair number of people who shared that perception that it
remained unfinished for the audience of the Godly preachers was by 1603
significantly larger,
significantly more literate,
significantly more likely to have a better knowledge of the Bible and of the
prayer book significantly more likely to have read some of the English language
religious publications in the Puritan tradition which were pouring from the
pressers.
People are more deeply involved in a vernacular religious culture,
much of it produced by puritans who had abandoned their political opposition,
but who had emerged as the most active evangelicals,
the most earnest,
the most godly counselors of the Protestant tradition in the parishes
at this level.
The later reformation was perhaps mostly undramatic,
except in the private drama of personal conversion.
But if the situation of 1600 was one of relative calm,
it was also storing up the seeds of future drama.
Protestantism was gradually working its way into popular culture.
The Puritan minority was extending its influence,
not as a political movement,
but as a widespread religious style hostility to what was described as popery
was increasingly widespread and tensions remained regarding what the nature of
English Protestantism should be.
And they would give rise,
as we will see later,
to what have been called England's wars of religion in the 17th century
disputes,
not between Catholics and Protestants that was perhaps largely settled by 1600
but disputes between different conceptions of what it was to be a protestant.
Okay.
And next time I'll turn to other aspects of Elizabeth's reign,
and in particular the modes of political participation and the Queens
relationship with our counselors.